the question we have to raise is what
are the costs of the benefits that we
get from technology because there is
always a cost to everything that we gain
nothing is free and so of course of
course our mobile phones are fantastic
never again will we ever have to have
the question of I don't know who was in
that movie right what was the name of
that actor that those that's that's from
the 8th our children will never know
what it's like to live in perpetual
frustration of not being able to
remember a song right technology is
amazing absolutely you can stay in
contact with friends and family that
live around the world that you can't
just easily
I remember when folk we used to time how
long I was on the phone with my
grandmother who lived in London when we
lived in America because it was so
expensive and now it's like no big whoop
you know I remember those days
so technology's amazing but at what cost
there's always a balance and we have to
remember the balance and the balance of
Technology in this day and age means
that we're connected but we're not
necessarily connecting it means that
technology also has addictive qualities
that are most closely associated with
gambling we cannot be alone from our
telephones like if you have to go to the
loo and you run around looking for your
phone because you can't go to the loo
without your phone you probably have an
addiction you know if you wake up in the
morning you look at your telephone
before you say good morning to the
person sleeping next to you it's
probably a problem right and I think we
have to like any addiction managed event
like alcohol is fun too much alcohol is
bad gambling is fun too much gambling is
bad right like it's not a question of
good or bad it's a question of quantity
and balance that we use it and I think
absolutely we live in a world in which
technology it's not that the technology
is necessarily outpaced our evolution
because it's it's always done that the
question is what are we doing to balance
off the the negative side effects of
those advantages and I think we become
we we forget that
[Music]